– Und ich könnte nach der Ausbildung
wirklich bei dir arbeiten?
– Ja. Das ist mein Angebot. Du müsstest es
nur wollen und du müsstest dafür arbeiten.
– Okay, ich will es!
Also, wie geht's jetzt weiter?
– Zuerst müsstest du deine spanischen
Zeugnisse übersetzen lassen.
Sobald du einen Platz an
der Berufsschule hast,
kannst du mit der Ausbildung beginnen.
– Und ich kann die Ausbildung
wirklich bei dir machen?
– Ja. Mein Fahrradladen ist ein
Meisterbetrieb. Ich darf auch ausbilden.
– Und ich wäre nach drei Jahren mit der
Ausbildung fertig?
– Genau. Und ich hätte einen
top Mitarbeiter!
– Gut. Muss ich bei der Übersetzung
der Zeugnisse irgendwas beachten?
Ich meine:
Sind die deutschen Schulabschlüsse
anders als die in Spanien?
– Etwas anders schon.
Es gibt den Hauptschulabschluss,
den Realschulabschluss und das Abitur.
Das kannst du auf dem Gymnasium machen.
– Aber ich könnte mit meinem spanischen
Abschluss hier studieren?
– Das ist kein Problem.
Aber frag lieber noch mal nach.
– Okay. Ich erkundige mich, ob das mit
meinem spanischen Abschluss funktioniert.
Hier steht noch, dass ich einen Nachweis
über meine Deutschkenntnisse brauche.
– Du müsstest die B1-Prüfung machen.
– Dann muss ich auf jeden
Fall noch ’ne Menge lernen …
– Glaubst du, du kannst das schaffen?
– Auf jeden Fall!
– Ich bin stolz auf dich!